next we're going to talk about
innovation we may be less than a year
into the life of the ps4 but already
we're thinking about how we can improve
the game experience both this year and
also in years to come system software
2.0 includes a whole range of new
features including an intuitive friend
finder which will enable you to search
for real world friends by online ID and
also see recommendations of players that
you already know we've also added the
ability to upload shared videos to
YouTube but the feature of system
software 2.0 that we're most excited
about is share play share play will
allow any PlayStation Plus member to do
the following first you can invite any
friend anywhere to take turns playing
any of your games with you effectively
passing the controller to your friend
virtually no matter where they are
second you can invite another
PlayStation Plus number to play together
with you in the same session either
cooperatively or competitively in
essence sitting on the couch together
but again no matter where your friend is
what's special about share play is that
your friends do not need to own or
download the game
system software 2.0 including share play
comes to PlayStation 4 this autumn and
we'll take the ps4 socially connected
experience to a whole new level now I
want to talk about some of the
innovation of the future and first
project Morpheus project Morpheus is a
breakthrough innovation that takes your
gaming experience to an entirely
different place with morpheus you're
transported into other worlds with full
360 degree immersion look up down and
around to capture every detail of the
world's you choose to visit for obvious
logistical reasons Morpheus is not a
concept that can be readily demonstrated
on a big stage like this but we have
Morpheus playable here in Cologne and I
urge you to try it for yourself and see
why some of the leading players in our
industry are incredibly excited by
virtual reality and what Morpheus has to
offer next PlayStation now the concept
the PlayStation now is explained at
length at e3 introducing a streaming
service of this nature in Europe is
complicated and difficult and we've
always said that we will not introduce
PlayStation now until we can guarantee
proper PlayStation levels of quality
anywhere that we launch so I'm pleased
to announce tonight the PlayStation now
is coming to Europe in 2015 with the
first beta beginning in the UK finally
PlayStation TV we were thrilled at the
reaction PlayStation TV got at e3
PlayStation TV functions as a gaming
console that gives access to most PS
Vita titles as well as ps1 and PSP
classics and and this is something that
we're particularly excited about as a
way to enjoy Remote Play functionality
by pairing your ps4 with a second
television in your home PlayStation TV
is a versatile entry-level option for
the gamer and PlayStation TV will launch
across the PAL territory on November the
14th priced at 99 euros including three
digital games